sur les réseaux sociaux à chaque
nouvelle journée son challenge et tik
tok ne déroge pas à la règle
après le wine challenge le boss
challenge voici un challenge plus
sulfureux le silhouette challenge le
principe un défi qui permet aux filles
de se dénuder et de montrer leurs
courbes en créant des visuels de
silhouette grâce à des filtres tik tok
une façon de créer des vidéos érotiques
sans jamais se faire censurer par les
algorithmes un challenge qui fait un
véritable carton
ces dernières heures des milliers de
jeunes s'exhibe donc en ombres chinoises
sur un fond rouge est une musique
sensuelle
sauf que voilà si cela peut paraître bon
enfant le public de cette application
est surtout constituée de jeunes
internautes de 10 à 14 ans des jeunes
qui regardent des contenus pour le moins
inadaptée et qui sont parfois les
auteurs de ces vidéos déplacer pour des
jeunes gens de leur âge alors silhouette
challenge êtes vous choqué par ce
challenge jugée trop sexy allégeant de
trois personnes qui sont choqués alors
j'adore 1 alors moi la lecture ça hyper
sexy c'est vachement bien mais je vais
essayer de le faire
moi je suis très voyez géraldine meetic
tonnes dont déjà c'est pas pour toi
comment tu sais toi parce que tu es
beaucoup trop et là il a dit il a décidé
dans sa poche
c'est plus les jeunes filles et les
jeunes garçons sait très bien que la
plupart du temps sont mineurs vous l
avais parlé ici même bien sûr qu'il ya
plein de gens qui restent à pire est
qu'ils sont bons cela et quand des avis
enfin maxime tutoriels vidéos des idées
mal placées bien franchement moi je
trouve que ça fait super pourquoi les
idées mal placées
on va on va demander à celles qui
passent le plus de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux de nous tous c'est kenny crème
voilà et étant donné que je passe
beaucoup de temps sur réseaux sociaux et
ans quand un jeune il veut se [ __ ] à
poil
il faut à poil donc moi je préfère qu'il
se met à poil dans l'ombre comme ça et
qu on le devine donc on le voit à poil
son corps et sa petite tape la tête mais
oui je préfère c'est l'enfer en cuir
mais tu es encore des ceintures ou pas
je vais y aller moi je préfère plutôt qu
en réel parce que malheureusement ceux
qui veulent se montrer et son total et
se monteront en réel
scotché famille il ya d'autres tendances
comme le bund showing c'est à dire qu'il
faut montrer sa poitrine c'est une autre
tendance qui émerge de ça c'est la seule
chose c'est la même chose il ya le
invisible filter sait on se met à poil
juste on se met ou louer devant là c'est
encore une déclinaison de ça c'est
dangereux c'est un pervers c'est un ya
pédophiles les vidéos ne sont pas tous
été prouvée et aujourd'hui on les use it
pas besoin que ce à quoi la grande dame
allait avoir plus de followers et c'est
ça que tu encourages mais non qu'est
j'aimerais que la voix de la sagesse la
voie de la sagesse n'ont pas voulu avec
gilles pagny la dent de sagesse
pernikoff on revient en arrière parce
qu'il ya trois semaines on avait une
émission on avait aimé non plus j'aime
bien la même chose on a fait l'émission
à trois semaines entre autres sur tik
tok a prévu que le lendemain le contrôle
parental tik tok s'est exprimé après sa
mission a annoncé qu'il renforçait le
contrôle parental
là je suis désolé je suis pas un vieux
con on dirait une vitrine d'amsterdam à
un moment donné on a peur pour nos
enfants mais vous savez très bien que
derrière il ya aucun contrôle dans le
rouge à lèvres
les formater on s'est dit les battre ses
rivaux nommé deux secondes 91 ans
prénommé dit des choses graves il dit on
va être exposé à ça est ce que tu es au
courant qu'il ya des trucs porno qui
sont déjà ex préfère que les enfants il
voit des trucs comme ça que des 100 kg
hopley champions et bien c'est en bleu
mais ces lignes le gentil genton le gens
qui chantent on élit les jeunes ils se
mettent pas à presles parce qu'ils ont
envie de le faire c'est parce qu'il ya
une dictature sur les réseaux sociaux
qui est mathématique vous postez des
consuls sexy plus vous avez de like donc
comme ya plein de jeunes et
malheureusement des mineurs qui veulent
à tout prix existait avoir des lacs
alors que par ailleurs sa sur instagram
ils se sentent obligés de poser de
manière dénudées brin que je préfère les
voir que cela se développe
inconsciemment c'est à dire que se
mettre à poil c'est valorisant
socialement c'est horrible et pour elle
répond parce que je t'ai dis mais qu'est
ce que tu me suis dit voilà c'est les
réseaux sociaux si l'auto sociaux qui
les force à se mettre à poil et faut
dire aux gens que c'est nul de faire
aller général
et justement personne ne le sait cacher
kelly que c'est très dangereux
c'est désinhibante érotisation gracieuse
aux nerfs bien là j'ai regardé chez nero
tease à sion dangereuse du corps des
jeunes
ça valait désinhibé vous ils vont se
montrer parce qu'ils sont tous cette
unité sont déjà perçus mélo sont pas du
genre à ne pas déjà transfert de
historiques comme ici oui 68% voilà les
gens sont chauds pièce et non à 32% et
ben voila voulait bien de le cul cul du
loup